fils
ont développé une cyber dépendance
programmeur-analyste de formation et
ministre responsable de tout le volet
informatique du gouvernement eric r
connaît mieux que quiconque les dérives
des écrans donc était accro à tous les
jeux le conte connaît
ça a été jusqu'à se lever toutes les
nuits pour pour jouer pour pour être
capable d'aller chercher çà çà çà drogue
il s'est rendu très loin là d'un très
très loin là dedans il est arrivé un
événement
extrêmement malheureux grave qui nous
oblige à prendre des décisions qui
étaient absolument cruel sa mère et moi
avec beaucoup d'émotion il nous raconte
comment son fils de 14 ans a dû être
sevré dans un centre de traitement des
dépendances comme celui où intervient
marie josée michaud c'est quelque chose
que une tendance à la hausse
présentement c'est certain que nos
mesures sanitaires sont venus un peu
augmenté nos facteurs de risque pour
l'enfant de nos jeunes l'école en ligne
qui limite les rencontres avec les amis
elle constate les effets pervers du
confinement un volume d'appels plus
important mais surtout je vous dirais
une détresse plus important de la part
des parents au delà des campagnes de
prévention en cours le ministre lionel
carmant promet un plan d'action
qu'on veut se trouver la ligne où on
peut permettre son utilisation de façon
sécuritaire et en fait que ça devient un
outil positif pour nos jeunes 35 % des
adolescents affirment que leur
utilisation des écrans a nui à leurs
résultats scolaires
45% ont perdu le sommeil pour cette
raison au point où la famille du quart
d'entre eux s'est inquiété selon des
chiffres colligés par la santé publique
de montréal auprès de 700 jeunes durant
la troisième vague ce soit que si on
veut juste dire aux jeunes l'envié aux
écrans
le chercheur jean françois biron note
que 25 % des ados ont passé plus que
cinq heures par jour sur les écrans
durant leur temps libre au printemps
dernier les barreaux la
maligne ou scolaires en europe
l'appartement d'ailleurs dès cet automne
dans chaque école secondaire il va avoir
des intervenants dépendance les
différents organismes communautaires et
on veut qu'ils participent à cette
promotion de l'utilisation saine des
écrans il faut documenter ça qu'il faut
s'assurer que les parents vont être
outillés pique les jeunes vont avoir des
ressources des ressources qui ont permis
de traiter son enfant il est capable
d'identifier quand ça devient concept
devient excessif et sault ste c'est un
processus qui prend qui prend du temps
ici véronique prince radio canada qui